10 thank you
hi welcome to game in Max's 100 seconds
New Year's Eve no seriously though what
a great holiday you got your champagne
toasts kissing french kissing yeah that
but let's be real you'd have to be a
fiddy Otoo not gay holiday well max does
have a point New Year's Eve is one of
the most sacred times for couples if
you're in a relationship it is a
romantic high holiday fun fact ten out
of ten couples actually choose to get
married on New Year's Eve that's why
it's so important to plan a perfect and
amazing evening for you and your lover
you know because if you slip up a little
bit Bam's you will cheat on you what are
your plans Gabe I'm actually going to
call my son and see if he wants to get
dinner at the buffet at Ruby Tuesday's
yours I didn't even realize you had a
son mmm do you see him often hmm what
are your new year's plans max uh well
four years eve I got some pretty crazy
plans I'm gonna buy a boat yeah I'm
gonna buy a boat so i'll be at the boat
store there's you got to get a new
license and now there's mooring stuff in
their paperwork stuff and then the sail
around the world making sure no one's
ever cheated on me but this is so juice
what does he like he plays a lot of
lacrosse that's awesome do you like go
to games or what are you going to call
your boat turok cheater hunter but look
this is a new thing I haven't heard one
word about this until now it's trying to
get my family back just want to get that
get them all back